Translator: Jennifer Cody
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
When faced with a big challenge
where potential failure seems
to lurk at every corner,
maybe you've heard this advice before:
"Be more confident."
And most likely, this is what you think
when you hear it:
"If only it were that simple."
But what is confidence?
Take the belief that you are valuable,
worthwhile, and capable,
also known as self-esteem,
add in the optimism that comes
when you are certain of your abilities,
and then empowered by these,
act courageously
to face a challenge head-on.
This is confidence.
It turns thoughts into action.
So where does confidence even come from?
There are several factors
that impact confidence.
One: what you're born with,
such as your genes,
which will impact things like the balance
of neurochemicals in your brain.
Two: how you're treated.
This includes the social pressures
of your environment.
And three: the part you have control over,
the choices you make,
the risks you take,
and how you think about
and respond to challenges and setbacks.
It isn't possible to completely untangle
these three factors,
but the personal choices we make
certainly play a major role
in confidence development.
So, by keeping in mind
a few practical tips,
we do actually have the power to cultivate
our own confidence.
Tip 1: a quick fix.
There are a few tricks that can give you
an immediate confidence boost
in the short term.
Picture your success
when you're beginning a difficult task,
something as simple as listening to music
with deep bass;
it can promote feelings of power.
You can even strike a powerful pose
or give yourself a pep talk.
Tip two:
believe in your ability to improve.
If you're looking for a long-term change,
consider the way you think
about your abilities and talents.
Do you think they are fixed at birth,
or that they can be developed,
like a muscle?
These beliefs matter because
they can influence how you act
when you're faced with setbacks.
If you have a fixed mindset,
meaning that you think your talents
are locked in place,
you might give up,
assuming you've discovered
something you're not very good at.
But if you have a growth mindset
and think your abilities can improve,
a challenge is an opportunity
to learn and grow.
Neuroscience supports the growth mindset.
The connections in your brain do get
stronger and grow with study and practice.
It also turns out, on average,
people who have a growth mindset
are more successful,
getting better grades,
and doing better
in the face of challenges.
Tip three: practice failure.
Face it, you're going to fail sometimes.
Everyone does.
J.K. Rowling was rejected by
twelve different publishers
before one picked up "Harry Potter."
The Wright Brothers built on history's
failed attempts at flight,
including some of their own,
before designing a successful airplane.
Studies show that those who fail regularly
and keep trying anyway
are better equipped to respond
to challenges and setbacks
in a constructive way.
They learn how to try
different strategies,
ask others for advice,
and perservere.
So, think of a challenge
you want to take on,
realize it's not going to be easy,
accept that you'll make mistakes,
and be kind to yourself when you do.
Give yourself a pep talk,
stand up, and go for it.
The excitement you'll feel knowing that
whatever the result,
you'll have gained greater knowledge
and understanding.
This is confidence.